good afternoon everyone thank you all
for joining here today I had a good
evening in a really good morning spent
time getting briefed by generals
McKenzie and his team at CENTCOM and
general Clarke and his team and SOCOM
the purpose of my visit was to come down
here and make sure that the State
Department the department defense were
deeply coordinated across a whole broad
range of issues we certainly discussed
the ongoing tension in the Gulf but we
talked about a much broader range of
issues if if we're to deliver at the
State Department on the president's
diplomatic objectives we have to be a
tightly woven with our military and I
appreciate general McKenzie general
Clark and their teams spending time with
me and my team today to make sure we
were doing just that we had extensive
conversations about tactical operational
strategic levels of work between our two
organizations to make sure that when we
present options alternatives policy
recommendations to president Trump we're
doing so in a way that is coherent and
consistent and leads the president to a
fuller understanding of the challenges
and opportunities connected to a
decisions that he makes we certainly as
I said spoke about the challenges that
are in Iran we talked about the CENTCOM
decision that Secretary Shanahan and the
president approved to move a thousand
more Americans into theater to make sure
that we're in a position to do the right
thing which is to continue to work to
convince the Islamic government of Iran
that we are serious and to deter them
from further aggression in the region
it's been our mission since the
beginning of this administration to
convince the Iranian regime not to move
forward with their nuclear program and
not to continue to engage in development
of their missiles and all the other
activities the malign activities that
they've been engaged in around the world
that's why we put in place the pressure
campaign that's now been ongoing for a
year and a couple months it's been very
effective and now we need to make sure
that we continue to do that so that we
ultimately get the opportunity to
convince Iran
it's not in their best interest to
behave in this way we all have to
remember this isn't just two and a half
years or five years this is 40 years of
Iranian activity that has led us to this
point and to reestablish deterrence is a
challenge but one that I know the Trump
administration is up to and we're
working hard each and every day both in
the State Department and the Department
of Defense and all the elements the
United States government to achieve that
and with that I'm happy to take a couple
questions yes ma'am
the situation almost certainly President
Trump had sent president Ave to take a
message of his to the leadership in Iran
you have to remember these are messages
for the leadership I think the Iranian
people are being woefully Mis served by
that leadership but yes we're engaged in
we have been engaged in many messages
even this this moment right here
communicating to Iran that we are there
to deter aggression President Trump does
not want war and we will continue to
communicate that message while doing the
things that are necessary to protect
American interests in the region will
continue to provide additional
information about those attacks we
shouldn't focus on just those two
attacks there since the beginning of May
there are now over a half dozen
different instances of Iranian attacks
in the region some thwarted some not not
successfully thwarted next they had an
impact but I saw just as I walked in
here Chancellor Merkel say that she
thought there was strong evidence that
Iran had engaged in this activity will
continue to work with partners all
around the world it's worth reminding
everyone here you have China that
depends enormous ly on energy transiting
the Strait of Hormuz you have South
Korea Indonesia Japan all of whom have
an enormous interest in ensuring there's
freedom of navigation throughout this
waterway the United States is prepared
to do its part but every nation that has
a deep interest in protecting that
shipping lane so that energy can move
around the world and support their
economies needs to make sure they
understand the real threat the real
threat to their interests in the region
and the real threat to their countries
economies if we're not successful in
doing that
like falls within the operation
operating theater of US central up to
Special Operations Command at Central
Command what do you say to the families
of the men and women who work within
those commands about how they should
prepare themselves for what may come
with next year's look the first thing I
do is say thank you to them for their
service to the nation I know many of
these young men and women they are
talented capable aggressive they have
put us in the place where we have this
opportunity to deter Iran and what I
would what I'd say to them is what I say
to everyone who is engaged in this kind
of service America is deeply
appreciative we are providing them with
the resources they need to be successful
to continue to engage in the activities
in a way that will deliver good outcomes
and to thank them for their willingness
to take this ultimate risk that every
service member faces I remind my
diplomats all around the world they too
face threats to them to themselves and
to their families and when I get a
chance to talk to those officers at the
State Department those diplomats I tell
the same thing I'd like to share with
the families that are here at CENTCOM
and SOCOM thank them for their amazing
professionalism work in their
willingness to serve America at these
challenging times
you
you
about each of those and how to make sure
that we were in sync and how we would
prepare those options for the president
united states coming here to Tampa to
talk with generals rather than talk with
generals at the Pentagon and should your
trip here be a message to Iran so I
talked with generals at the Pentagon all
the time too so these are not mutually
exclusive options but it was important
for me to get here into the into the
headquarters where where a lot of this
work is doing it let it make sure we
didn't have to send a whole bunch of
folks up to meet me in Washington I got
a chance to meet with not only those two
leaders but their teams today and they
got a chance to turn to hear how the
State Department is thinking about this
problems and how we're delivering
deterrence in the region and reinforced
with them the strategic objectives of
the United States of America so it was
it was important and valuable to me to
get here so that I could talk to a
broader range of leaders and here at a
more granular level all of the great
work that they've been engaged in great
I'll take one more
I don't have anything to add to that we
sounds say only this it is the case that
in May we had over 140,000 illegal
immigrants entered to this nation
unlawfully it is an important
undertaking to ensure that we have
sovereignty and security to our southern
border and so every action this
administration is taking is designed to
do just that president Trump's has been
unambiguous very clear we worked I
worked personally on an arrangement with
Mexico now a week and a few days ago I
am confident that we will get that under
control and it is important it's
important for American national security
that we do in fact achieve that thank
you all